nature has always been an integral part
of my life it's a place where i feel the
most at peace
people who have visual impairment really
have very limited access to the outdoors
to fix this problem i created a braille
trail
[Music]
meet evan a 19 year old who founded
nature for all an organization that
helps provide nature experiences for the
visually impaired
there are numerous challenges that
visually impaired people face when they
try to enjoy nature
like uneven footing and not being able
to read the signs
okay now you should be able to guide
yourself a bro trail has
guide rope and signage and braille
so the visually impaired can walk along
it unassisted it highlights sensory
experiences
such as touching leaves and textured
bark now everybody can enjoy nature he
first came up with the idea to make his
own braille trail after he saw one that
was vandalized i was 11 years old when i
started getting involved with braille
trails i couldn't believe that anybody
would vandalize a trail and take away
the opportunity that the visually
impaired so seldom have to go out and
experience nature
my name is marcia farrow and i have
retinitis pigmentosa marcia has been
visually impaired since elementary
school i have always loved nature
i feel that i can be independent when
i'm out at a braille trail and that this
is an area that i can enjoy and relax a
little bit without having to be so
anxious about what's coming ahead
since evan started his organization rail
trails have been popping up all over the
world and his website keeps tabs on
their location currently the website has
over 200 bro nature trails and sensory
gardens 35 countries on six continents
accessible outdoor opportunities can
bridge the barrier between people with
disabilities and the world outside
and that goes for evan too i've become a
lot closer
with the visually impaired community
they have such a positive outlook on
life despite what they go through
and really they can do just about
anything that we can do they are really
my role models
[Music]
you